les orléans c'était un rat table quoi
pour les gens qui aiment la musique
abbas et c'était quand même un événement
un événement sur orléans oui l'événement
où il ya presque dix mille personnes il
ya des premiers gros concert qui a eu à
orléans je pense et que j'avais co
organisé à l'époque avec mes associés de
maintenant jules frutos et len rhodes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ambiance qu'on peut plus avoir
maintenant c'est à dire en fumée avec
des zones d'odeurs un peu différentes
selon les endroits
et puis
mais bonne humeur quoi je serai bien que
c'était au sofitel saluer avant
maintenant c'est le mercure orléans
avant ça s'appelle sofitel au bord de la
loire et il avait réservé tout un étage
tout un étage autant dire que c'était le
brouillard complet dans le couloir et
non seulement le brouillard parce qu'il
fumait beaucoup mais aussi parce qu'ils
accueillir lors leur poisson lors tous
leurs plats là haut avec les mama qui
était qu'ils aient qui faisait la
cuisine
c'était lors il adore propre cuisine
dans les chambres d'hôtel je me souviens
très bien du dernier morceau de woodson
sang'' de bob marley qu'était c'était
une un nouveau morceau je crois de de
bob marley qui était magnifique il a
fait ça tout seul à la guitare est bon
on n'avait pas encore on sait pas ça pas
encore qu'il est et qu'il était sur la
fin mais bon voilà c'était c'était très
très en retrait
à temps plein et entier comme on a des
mondialistes en deux tailles
[Musique]
c'était un super concert de reggae
c'était même un grand frisson d'avoir le
dieu du vélo du reggae y a pas plus
grandes stars que bob marley en 80
c'était pas possible autrement
voilà donc effectivement d'avoir ce ce
mec en face et le croiser aussi dans les
backstage du parc exposition c'était
quelque chose
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]